[Musique]
s'il vous plaît assez coûte un peu j'en
profite pour souhaiter la bienvenue à la
nouvelle série intel samia zip rar sauf
toi jeune cpe dans qu'il en est encore
temps
pourquoi madame johanne mythe vous êtes
un troisième c'est une année très
importante pour moi monsieur en phase
avec la nouvelle coupe en ont déjà un
vrai d'un an maintenant juste sur le
daron calme-toi un peu je te rappelle
quand même fait à 19 ans car en double
et plus de 7 fois d'accord que tu as ton
fils qui ont 6ème juste à côté c'est pas
bien vous avez pas le droit
sony s'attend de change et du roussillon
c'est toi qui a fondé une érection en
fait ouais ouais toujours eu envie de
travailler en équipe
moi je veux bien être sans faille et
aucun problème assez juste faut pas me
prendre pour un con
yanis tu cherches au koala tu veux te
faire exclure direct dès le début de
l'année c'est ça mais je te préviens moi
j'ai pas de lâcher l'athée sur une
mauvaise pente et c'est trop dommage
parce que moi je sais que tu vaux mieux
que ça et si je vais aller pas mieux que
ça
elle me suis déjà allé moi c'était
compliqué quand la belgique moto vous
mettez des lettres et du français et de
maths consulter les mathématiques c'est
des clés parmi toutes les clés qu'on
essaiera de vous donner pour que vous
puissiez choisir votre avenir
sérieusement dans ses fans je voulais
des comptes à bout des banquiers
[Musique]
déjà qu'on est dans une ville de kara
posera quartier de ker et vous votre
idée c'est de regrouper tous ses fois
ensemble
c'est ça votre projet pour nous
oh
[Musique]
si on signe à saint denis s'est pas
complètement commencé mi rieur
[Applaudissements]
d'arriver en retard à cause de la grève
oui à melen créé c'était une grève air
france et habite au bout de la rue non
j'avoue c'est là j'ai un peu abusé